[Music]
in disgruntled ex-employee news
like the intro wow
what a throwback i thought we weren't
doing those anymore submitted by i
thought we weren't doing that anymore oh
okay i think he knows it's good this guy
there's a worker who
tears down luxury homes with uh digger
as payback for getting fired
so we're gonna go and watch that video
because it's fun and you know it's a
little bit of a catharsis imagine
getting fired but you operate heavy
machinery it's pretty fun and you're
pissed
and he smashed his boss's house yeah uh
not his developments he was working on
some of the developments that are in the
area beautiful there's no lawsuits after
this it's like this is what i did
so now it's coming down i hope it's that
[ __ ] drilly spa leafy i like that
that was cool
it's uh like the wrecking ball it's a
it's a digger it's literally the ones
that like [ __ ] is that the one that
shredder has in the cartoon
those are the most boring ones
[Music]
oh that was a lake house
oh my god dude he just destroyed
optimus prime is not [ __ ] around that
hurts my feelings oh no it was so nice
you guys like no it's kind of fun though
right yeah it's it's okay
yeah i'm feeling it
[Laughter]
isn't that a thing like when you're a
contractor and you're working on a house
and then the people go we're not going
to pay for this or there's some reason
why they won't pay you sometimes the
contractor just starts [ __ ]
everything up that he built so they
don't have it
but then yeah yeah doesn't that ever ask
for that i don't yeah it's like you
technically can't unless like you've i
think there's like a little caveat like
if the contractor person had to front
the
the cost of the material so it's
technically their [ __ ] still
because it hasn't been transacted out i
don't know but there are times where the
the person like was tiling a bathroom
and they're like oh it's not coming out
how he wanted it we're not paying then
he goes oh you're not paying squat i
just bashed the whole [ __ ]
because that's gonna cost more for them
to like refix that
right damn that's when he hoped that
nationwide is understanding
yeah yeah tory kelly kelly comes and
saves the day
so a person believed to be a disgruntled
ex-employee uh was pretty much caught
filmed in the uh in this expensive
marina area in canada
obviously it's a lakeside property
that's getting [ __ ] up the scene was
captured by
bystanders before police officers
arrived
this area is called the pride of russo
marina on the banks of the muskoka lakes
when the coppers turned up a 59 sending
the mail sucks that [ __ ] sucks
a 59 year old man was arrested and
charged with mischief is the uh word
the mischief in question is obviously a
significant amount of damage to a pretty
expensive property
currently uh again just believed to be a
former worker at the very site he's been
fined with the equivalent of about like
five thousand dollars and a set for a
date in the courthouse buy geez that's
it what
dude this guy's cheap i want to use this
guy where where is this this is in
canada canada maybe it's nicer in canada
they're like
thing worked out for 5 000 bucks to them
is like oh man that's that's a lot
that's a lot
they're just like why'd you do this like
i was just fired they're like oh i get
it i get it uh maybe 5 000.
that's easy taken on july 21st the
footage shows the red machinery tearing
through the second floor of the pride
marina group building by the lake
one observer tweeted you can't make this
up a disgruntled fired employee from a
marine nero lake house snapped and
destroyed the entire marina with an
excavator so he took that whole house
out he ends up taking out a lot of the
house i think there's still a couple
pieces of foundation up there but i
don't think oh boy
yeah you know i don't i don't think it's
right to like
take your
anger out on phys like things you know i
think it's just wrong when you want to
like don't you like
cause all these holes what what
wait what
yeah there's some
yeah hey editors don't cut to anything
don't don't cut it down the other side
did those yeah if you guys caught two
you're gonna make joe look like [ __ ]
don't cut two don't do it like it's just
i don't know have his [ __ ] back for a
change you gotta control your [ __ ]
emotions yeah
like yeah yeah
that's good you're hating
dude
will you run for mayor already they
don't have anything on you by the way
there's not like all kinds of footage of
you saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] or anything
like you're good dude
you'll win you know what
i think i'll i'll do it i think you
should thank you
why stop at mayor with a record like
that i need to start small maybe like
city of fresno or bakersfield yeah and
then i'll work my way up to district
country
oh it's gonna be easy there should be an
assemblyman oh assemblyman they're
[ __ ] yeah dude
ambassador
representative of district 32
you know
dude imagine joe's representative of
anything and then he's in there like
[ __ ] hookers and [ __ ] and then the
cops show up and then he's like i
thought i had diplomatic community or
some [ __ ]
in your own country
[Music]
does it show why this guy got
disgruntled in the first place
like i watched part of that movie i
can't remember
dude just just looking just looking at
the video on how the houses are by like
a body of water it just reminds me of my
cousins out in texas
they live like in this community that's
like really like it's beautiful like
corpus christi huh corpus christi uh no
like sugarland
yeah sugarland that's in houston yeah
yeah so like um they live in this
property where it's like it's definitely
it has an hoa and i think like their
houses are at least like four bedrooms
and it's all for a hundred grand it's
like lakes lakeside yeah yeah it's kind
of like a lake do they talk with a
southerner they have like a bunch of
like fields and then there's like
gazebos and stuff like that and i just
remember asking them because like they
they were visiting us recently
and um i was asking them like how much
their hoa was and they were like oh it's
like 1400 and i was like
hundred holy [ __ ] and then they're like
oh it's 1400 a year and i'm like a year
fourteen hundred a year for your hoa
that's actually pretty tight it just
hurts it hurts to know that because hoa
here in california [ __ ] sucks it's
like on average like it ranges from like
three hundred fourteen hundred a year
here for a [ __ ] shitty apartment
where a bum is taking a dump in front of
your life
yeah you still deal with everything 1400
a month here
bro my my old pad had it was 350 a month
and all they had was a bunch of flower
beds in the [ __ ] property there's no
pool no nothing
like why what the hell where's the money
going to they say the roof but i'm like
bro i can't see it i can't make a [ __ ]
it hurts it's called sugarland
how much was their house like 400 grand
for a mansion i don't remember i didn't
ask them about did they have a southern
accent i bought it like years ago like
were they like welcome welcome to
it's like sugarland like that you have
to say sugarland texas welcome to
sugarland usa oh honey i'm at 1400 a
year bless your heart
come inside for some tea sugar
well come on in the sugar ladder honey
we can't vote here but it sure is nice
we can't vote here
does that make you want to move to texas
no no no no i like california too much
because like all my family my friends
and like my work is out here and yeah
but like i mean texas
it's pretty but it's also humid too not
a fan and they're bigger out there
you know how they got these babies in my
husband's penis
how many times i tell you not to talk
about my maintenance hey you know just
because i'm the only one here that can
vote you know i take your input at heart
now
you get out of the inflatable swimming
pool right now woman it is way too late
the meatloaf she's gonna get all wrinkly
not that she's not wrinkly already
wrangling get it
i'm picturing them we're going to have
an outlet mall as far as the eye can see
one day you'll see one day
there's going to be a jc penny right
there julius
and guess gene
and maybe not to be too crazy with ihop
oh yes
that'll be the crown jubilee
[Laughter]
people from all the way from plato texas
to east southern plano texas he's going
to be coming all the way here
sugarland
you need to be a city developer
i would only run as a character
you probably work in all of the [ __ ]
middle states where the tornados are i
think so where i'm from yeah
indiana
that's
that's that's a true story somewhere
yeah that is this is a real one
this is a real guy there's somebody out
there that's like man i wish i had an
ihop out here
[Laughter]
outlets out there as far as yeah i can
see mama we gotta leave this [ __ ]
countryside
we came out here to land opportunity all
we got out here is a is a local bar and
a spit bucket
and a dollar general
[Music]
you